made an annual las vegas tradition that
benefits opportunity village is going to
look a little different this year of
course
camelot is going to be virtual and to
tell us more about that we're joined by
adam joseph from opportunity village
first of all adam for those who haven't
been around tell us about camelot what
is it
keto it's great to be on with you guys
today and camelot is one of our
long-standing fundraisers at opportunity
village
we serve adults that have intellectual
and developmental disabilities and from
the comfort of your home tomorrow night
and the safety of your home
you can watch all the wonderful
programming participate in the awesome
auction
having those awesome libations that you
can mix in your house all you have to do
is visit
camelotov.com to make your ticket
purchases today yeah you've got a great
lineup of talent
we do shin lim lance burton pif the
magic dragon i talked about those
libations
silent auction that's already going on
and then the live auction is going to
kick off about 7 10 tomorrow night
again just visit camelotov.com to
purchase your tickets today
and every year you have a specific
honoree this year i understand it's wind
resorts
yeah wind resorts a long-standing
partner of opportunity village
and what's important about recognizing
them kendall today is their amazing work
that they do for opportunity village but
also what they do to help the community
that we call home in southern nevada
adam tell people where they can buy
tickets so they can help out everybody
at opportunity village
that's right online camelotov.com
everything kicks off tomorrow night
at 6 30. tickets start at 150 you can
enjoy the
awesome programming visit camelotov.com
today
adam really appreciate it good luck this
year with everything
okay you guys be safe out there thank
you so much you too las vegas now we'll
be right back